one thing as I was rereading the books a
little bit just in preparation for this
interview which was in comparison with
our our modern system where law is
hierarchical and controlled by the state
there are lots of different sources of
legal authority in your world so
executions come in private and public
forms you know the public Ned Stark
execution the semi-public Karstark and
the night watchman was killed in the
beginning of the first book and then
very private executions by private
parties so what's the different one have
to make a distinction you know when when
Ned Stark execute the the dessert at the
beginning of book he he is acting under
proper legal authority as the Lord of
Winterfell but when he needs not acting
in the King's name even says that in a
little speech he gives right now in the
name of Robert of house Baratheon the
first of his name etcetera etc by the
hand of Eddard Stark there's a concept
which has touched on briefly in the in
the books of what the difference between
a lord and a knight you know there are
there's a hierarchical feudal system in
my world just as it was in real medieval
England and medieval Europe what's not
exactly the same I made a certain number
of changes in some ways simplifications
because as complex as Westeros in
seventeen the part of it nowhere near as
complex as what you actually got in the
real Middle Ages where you know you need
this probably books just understand the
relationships between some of the boards
and their bass holes and their their
ageism etc it got extremely complex
particularly the later you all use out
into the period so I don't have like the
17 titles of you know Baron
but you do have the heraldry tatra
always had you know in the real the real
world had different ranks I just have
boards at night and someone had asked me
what is the difference between them well
one of the differences the Lord has
what's called the power of pitting
gallows that is a wart has the power to
to punish to administer criminal law on
his own authority without having to go
to someone else while a knight even a
land at night who has very extensive
states and in some ways some of the big
land at nights may have larger estates
than some of the smaller boards but the
night does not have the power of hidden
cameras and pin gallows of course
gallows is the ability to execute
someone hit is the ability to confine
them in a dungeon or use the word power
I mean I mean there are lots of folks
who do execute people in the books who
are not Lords and so I guess what you're
saying is just a legitimate power right
so and and multiple sort of halfway
legitimate Kings where does that where
does the power come from in in your
world like where does the sovereignty
arise well as with medieval England is
there's a sense of the Authority derives
from the king and the King's authority
arrives from God is that why the church
is able to arrest the Queen for I think
it's adultery at the end of a feast
proposed well the church is a whole
nother issue we're sort of getting into
a side issue here the faith as I call it
mm-hmm I mean something that's sort of
you know in the in the u.s. there's
always before you get the church soon
yeah really say what I want that the
Lord's okay what I think you have to
keep in mind is the history of the Seven
Kingdoms hmm the fact of it although at
the time of
books it is one single realm in the past
that has been many different realms that
has been seven kingdoms who are really
were separate kingdoms at the time of
Aegon's conquest and if you go back
before that you know it's many more than
seven and hundreds of kingdoms hundreds
of tiny kingdoms and so some of these uh
crime lords of particular or kings in
their own right in at a certain point
and and they're still very powerful
wards so you don't get also some
regional differences would be inevitable
and some of the kings particularly the
kings who had never been conquered
i've never been forced to surrender who
can who can the Lord took a trace a
lineage back to the ancient kings who
predate the Targaryen conquest by
thousands of years they might have
traditions and rights that are a little
bit at variance with what a more
centralized regime would have because
you know at one time there's this
lingering tradition that they were their
own authority they were the ones
anointed by God or the gods in case of
Westeros right now the Church Hall comes
for a month the the faith of the seven
was a handle faith they're the second of
the human invaders who look at this into
the Seven Kingdoms or whatever you call
them we go back thousands of years for
our hundreds of kingdoms and they had
these seven gods and they're they're
probably the most organized and dominant
religion in the continent of Westeros
and the one the most resembles the
medieval Catholic Church and they didn't
have their own courts and they did have
their own systems of justice and
punishment for for sins of
transgressions and of course they won't
look powerful in before the conquest
before the conquest bomb you know you
had seven kingdoms but only one faith
and only one High Septon even though
there were seven kings which gave him a
lot of influence and they also had a
fighting arm and was much more powerful
in the days before
in conquest when there was one High
Septon but numerous smaller kings the
Targaryen conquests when when the Seven
Kingdoms were largely unified was
followed by a period of conflict between
state and Church in which the power of
the church was essentially broken by a
succession of turkey Aryan kings and
their rights to do some of these things
were diminished so by the time the
present series opens a Song of Ice and
Fire
the church is still only influential but
it's it's it's no longer the power it
was 300 years before of course you see
that painting during the course of the
books as a as a result of some of the
events of the books you know and a
series of new high septons come to power
and then the one that usually coming to
power and a feast for crows is very
determined to store the power of the
church right substance is equal to
weight performing right with the faith
militant who is their military arm
Nathan Dean the power key language you
know gives them sorts to back up the
decrees and essentially restores so the
reason why I found it as a player in the
game of pros right the reason why I
found it so interesting was you know an
ongoing issue in current political
debates in the country is sort of the
degree to which the executive can be
held to account in a civil court system
and and the the trial of Cersei the
Queen by the civil court system and the
church thought I thought was something
which today we are we had an analogue
right with with the President Clinton
being sued for sexual harassment in the
Supreme Court saying it was not going to
distract his presidency the question I
had was sort of do you have in mind
right where they tried in church court
where were they tried in the king's
court system I have no idea
well I mean that's interesting tubing
here that both of them were tried and
executed during a period of change where
you know the King had recently assumed
had to had driven the Pope and his
representatives out of England that
night that pointed himself the the head
of the Church of England he wasn't able
to get the result I mean he wanted the
divorce Catherine of Aragon he did take
it to the church
and you know he tried to work with
Cardinal Wolsey and a special emissary
was sent from Rome to hear the divorce
case but he didn't get the verdict that
he wanted right when he said well I'll
I'll take my old up is that the sort of
a historical period I thought the
historical period you had in mind was
maybe a little bit earlier then then
Henry they largely it is yes but on the
other hand it's not one for one I'm not
mistaking any particular event or or a
character from history and filing off
the serial numbers and right getting it
I'm moody sitting and matching a number
of things
sure on you know the Wars of the Roses
of people pointed out is certainly an
important influence on my book well I've
also looked at things like the Crusades
the at Mackenzie and crusade the
Crusades in the Middle East of the
Hundred Years War which was fascinating
are their wares in your books the gist
are often the wings of the stage that
haven't been that haven't yet appeared
that's it
you know that's an interesting question
I haven't really considered that until I
started reading here you're those links
that you said to me mm-hmm
there are certainly laws but is there a
special class of advocates who make
their living by interpreting those laws
I would my inclination is probably not
because you know a lot of the laws in my
books are administered by Lords in some
ways it's a government as much of much
more men than laws I mean like this they
are our government in United States as
government of laws
in some ways the Seven Kingdoms I think
is a reverse there is a basis of a war
well it awful lot depends on who is who
is interpreting it and you know who is
sitting in the Lord's seat who is
sitting on the Iron Throne and how they
how they settle these disputes well
those are ultimate questions but I mean
I think in two places I think one could
have imagined
lawyers and one of them again will be
this church trial no because there were
Church lawyers you know in the in the
classical church system there were
lawyers who specialized in canon law and
the second one was at least twice I can
think of in the books their trial by
combat and I don't really know what the
other alternative would be but I assume
would be trial by jury and that the past
that Tyron Tyrion did not choose both
times and I was thinking well he does
choose in the in the first uh in the
second second of his two trials he is
being tried it's not my jury
it's my lord you know there's no curry
of his peers no twelve people that are
randomly picked but there are three
Lords who are sitting on his case and
hearing the evidence right and you know
they pyro
I think is one of them I don't remember
the other two right well over and
Martell there were the red Viper is one
of them
it was bored of the sort of balance it
because they want a semblance of
impartiality of course it's a hopelessly
because his his father is that in some
ways the presiding judge is the end of
the King and his sister who's also the
daughter of the same father is the the
chief complaint against it no one who's
accusing him of doing these things but
that does have semblance of his trial
where you know witnesses are being
called forth people are swearing those
people were testifying right against him
and saying what they saw what they did
not saw at a certain point though Kiryat
realizes that he's
it's hopeful is he's losing that so he
exercises an option as a as a Lord to
request the trial by combat
instead when which was apparently went
over and says he'll stand for me thinks
he has a better chance there and he has
gotten off once before in the preceding
trial by combat where he rolled the dice
that way and they came up well for him
see I mean if the books were being
written by a law professor that would
have been the moment where the word
would have stepped in from the wings
right maybe there's a market there for a
brand new hybrid a series of medieval
John Grisham novels don't think that
there are a lot of my professors who
wouldn't like to be writing that exact
exact thing it would be sort of
interesting these are amazing is only
possible the medieval John Grisham novel
or the approach if you have a worldwide
line which is a relatively low magic
world